Six years ago,
when my older daughter was 13,
I bought her a vibrator.
(Cheers and applause)
I'm done. OK.
(Laughter)
It wasn't something I planned on doing.
I mean, I knew eventually my daughters
would need bras and tampons, maybe braces,
but a vibrator was not on the list.
So why did I do it?
Before I explain why,
I want to acknowledge
that I might have made
some of you a little uncomfortable
or a lot uncomfortable.
So before I explain why,
I want to ask you a question.
Why are we more comfortable
talking about female pain --
things like period cramps,
breast cancer, birthing pains,
miscarriages and sexual assault --
than we are talking about female pleasure?
Why does a vibrator make us uncomfortable
but Viagra does not?
(Cheers and applause)
Getting my daughter a vibrator
started me on a journey
of thinking about the importance
of empowering teenage girls,
helping them to learn about their bodies
and gain a sense of ownership
of their bodies,
including embracing
their right to pleasure.
This is one reason that my own daughters
encouraged me to include their stories
in this talk.
So I'm going to talk to you
today about sex,
specifically in regards
to our teenage daughters.
I know we don't like to think
about our teenagers having sex
and because of societal double standards,
especially our girls.
But here's why we need
to have this conversation,
as uncomfortable as it may make us.
Girls typically develop
a desire for sexual contact
between the ages of 11 and 14.
Between the ages of 15 and 19,
42 percent of them
have had vaginal and/or oral sex.
Through the cell phones
right in their back pockets,
57 percent of girls and 84 percent of boys
between the ages of 14 and 18
have watched pornography through
Pornhub and hundreds of similar sites.
So if you have a kid in high school,
it isn't a question of if they'll watch
porn before they graduate,
but more likely, when.
This means that a lot of our kids
are getting their sex education
and trying to figure out
what's normal from pornography.
To illustrate why we can’t leave our kids
alone to navigate this sexual terrain,
I want to share a story with you.
Several years ago,
I worked with an incredibly
intelligent 14-year-old girl,
helping her manage
her overall life stressors.
During one session, she asked
if she could ask me a question about sex.
She said that she was confused
about the bases
and wondered if it was really true
that second base was anal sex.
(Audience murmurs)
I was as shocked as you are.
And yes, when I asked her,
she did know what anal sex is.
She had gotten her information
from watching a few porn clips
her friends had showed her
during study hall at school.
Thankfully, because of the trusting
relationship she had with me,
she was able to have this
misconception corrected
and her anxiety about it relieved.
With her permission, I was also able
to loop her mom in on the conversation
so she could be a resource
for her daughter.
I've worked hard to cultivate this type
of relationship with my own daughters.
So when my 13-year-old said,
“Mom, can I ask you a question?” ...
kid speak for "be prepared for anything,"
(Laughter)
I listened.
Which is why, sitting at a stoplight
on a summer morning,
my daughter felt comfortable
telling me she had started to masturbate
and was even willing to share with me
what she was using to do so.
This is how I learned
that she was masturbating in a way
that was not safe for her body.
And so, in a span of one red light,
I decided to buy my daughter a vibrator.
I wanted to support her
in the safe exploration of her body
instead of burying my head in the sand,
which is so tempting to do as parents
with things that make us uncomfortable.
When it comes to sex,
we all need to become
trusted resources for our kids.
They need to be comfortable
coming to us with questions
and know they will get straight answers.
And while this is certainly true
in regards to accurate information,
sometimes it's also about giving
them the appropriate tool.
When we talk about girls
knowing and exploring their bodies,
it's easy to get uncomfortable.
But girls becoming familiar
with their bodies is about health.
Masturbation helps girls reduce stress,
ease headaches and alleviate cramps
associated with their periods.
When girls explore their bodies,
they learn how their bodies feel
when they are healthy,
which also helps them recognize changes
and potential problems.
They have to touch their bodies
to know their bodies.
This became clear to me
when I was working
with one of my adult clients
after her diagnosis
with stage four breast cancer.
As we discussed her prognosis,
she said to me,
"Robin, if I'd only done my breast checks,
maybe I would have caught it sooner.
Maybe I wouldn't be dying."
But my client had been raised believing
that touching herself was inappropriate.
On the few occasions
she did a breast check,
she didn't know what was typical,
and she rushed through them
feeling embarrassed.
When girls are comfortable
touching their bodies,
whether for self breast checks
or for pleasure,
they learn about their bodies.
And when they know their bodies,
they can better own their bodies.
This is important when it comes to sex.
Too often, others are dictating
what girls should expect,
want and put up with.
These expectations are being set
by pornography, social media, politicians
and partners who are either
much more experienced
or equally inexperienced.
I mean, let's face it.
What does the average teenage boy
know about the female clitoris
or the female orgasm?
(Laughter and applause)
Given the statistics that about 15 percent
of women have never had an orgasm
and 81 percent of women
do not orgasm through vaginal sex,
it is important for our girls to know
that it's OK to figure out
what gives them pleasure.
And that they don't have to rely
on someone else for that pleasure.
(Applause)
This can help them make choices
which benefit them.
As an example, another one of my clients
shared with me that she uses her vibrator
before she goes on any date.
(Laughter)
This way,
she can make judgments about the date
based on the person and their connection
rather than on hormones.
(Laughter)
And then when our daughters do decide
to have sex with someone else,
they will know enough
about their sexual pleasure
to be able to communicate
what feels good to their partners.
They won't have to follow
the outdated norms
of tolerating unsatisfying experiences,
faking it, or even believing
that their sole purpose
is to serve someone else's pleasure.
Our daughters will get the message
that their wants and needs are important.
Learning not to be ashamed
of their sexual pleasure
is not limited to girls and young women.
I worked with a 65-year-old woman
who had never, ever had an orgasm.
She came to me for coaching
because she felt demoralized.
She had recently retired
from her vice-president position,
feeling pushed out by her company
as they hired younger executives.
She had two goals for coaching.
The first was to find
new ways to spend her time
which gave her purpose.
The second one was, and I quote,
"to try out an orgasm."
(Laughter)
When she was ready,
my client bought herself a vibrator
and began learning about her body
for the first time in her life.
I will never forget the day
when she came to our session,
sat down demurely and said
with a big, beautiful grin,
"Second goal achieved."
(Laughter and applause)
As she continued to learn about herself
and her sexual pleasure,
my client stopped referring
to herself as old.
She accepted a board position
for a national nonprofit.
She even created a profile on eHarmony.
(Laughter)
Can I say it was simply due to the orgasm?
Of course not.
But in asking for more
from this one area of her life,
she realized she could do the same
in other areas of her life.
We can help our daughters
adopt this perspective
long before my client did.
We can support their
healthy sexual development,
but even more,
by doing so, we empower
their entire sense of selves.
This is about helping our girls
step into their power,
raising them to become strong women
who can speak up for themselves,
whether they are in the bedroom
or in the boardroom.
(Applause)
Recently, my younger
daughter reminded me
of just how well she can
speak up for herself.
(Laughter)
A few months ago,
she was out with friends and called
to let me know and she'd be home.
She's good like that.
As we were wrapping up
the conversation, she said,
"Oh, by the way, mom, my vibrator broke.
Can you pick me up a new one?"
(Laughter)
Later on, she told me
that after she hung up,
her friends said,
"We can't believe your mom
bought you a vibrator."
To which my daughter responded,
"I can't believe your moms haven't."
Thank you.
(Cheers and applause)